even before the meeting got started the
press were allowed in for a quick look
all right thank you folks the white
house signaled they were open to hearing
from republicans
but not necessarily reducing the amount
president biden wants to spend
it's important to him that he hears this
group out
on their concerns on their ideas he's
always open to making
this package stronger and the democrats
in the house and senate didn't wait for
the oval office sit down to move forward
with their one point trillion dollar
bill
putting in motion the process to try and
pass it without any support from the
opposition party
republican senators are hoping to spend
just 600 billion dollars
the two-hour meeting didn't appear to
produce any breakthroughs
i wouldn't say that we came together
on a package tonight no one expected
that
in a two-hour meeting but what we did
agreed to do
is to follow up and talk further
the republican plan would spend money on
fighting covid give some financial
supports the lowest earning americans
and the unemployed
and some money for schools to reopen but
it left out a key democratic demand
billions for states and cities who were
facing budget shortfalls and may have to
fire employees
like teachers firefighters garbage
collectors
it also didn't include raising the
federal minimum wage to 15 dollars an
hour over five years
president biden has said the need is
urgent and he promised voters that help
would quickly be on the way
but he also pledged to find compromise
in congress
now as they continue to negotiate the
question is
how long is he willing to wait to see if
he can fulfill
both big promises patti culhane al
jazeera
washington